[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn Beziehungen auseinandergehen ist
das ja meist schmerzlich erst recht wenn
ein der Partner dachte dass eigentlich
alles in Ordnung ist und dementsprechend
aus allen Wolken fällt wenn der oder die
andere Schluss macht hessens
Ministerpräsident Boris rin hat heute
Schluss gemacht mit den Grünen obwohl
die schwarzgrüne Koalition 10 Jahre
recht harmonisch lief was er im
Wahlkampf auch durchaus lobend erwähnt
hatte auch heute betonte er noch mal man
habe zehn gute Jahre miteinander gehabt
fehlte eigentlich nur noch der Satz lass
uns Freunde bleiben freuen kann sich nun
die SPD als ne ne Auserwählte die
Regierungsbeteiligung ist für sie ein
schönes Trostpflaster für ein historisch
schlechtes Wahlergebnis peterisen
berichtet als Nancy fer heute Abend das
Gebäude der neuen Denkerei in Kassel
betritt ist das bisher Undenkbare in
Hessen Realität es kommt wohl erstmals
zu einer großen Koalition im Land die
Zustimmung in der häsischen SPD gilt als
sicher ich freue mich sehr dass wir so
einmütig diesen Schritt gehen wollen und
jetzt dafür sorgen wollen dass wir vor
allening für die Menschen in Hessen das
Beste erreichen können wir leben in
Zeitalter von Krisen wo es darum geht
ihnen auch soziale Sicherheit zu geben
und ich glaube das kann in dieser
Konstellation zwischen der CDU und der
SPD auch gut funktionieren in diesen
Tagen Boris Rhein er will diese große
Koalition ohne große Not denn auffällig
geräuschlos arbeitete die CDU bisher mit
den Grünen in Hessen zusammen
schwarzgrün das war vor 10 Jahren eine
Annährung einstiger Erzfeinde eine
spannende neue Paarung damals
richtungsweisend eigentlich ein
Erfolgsmodell nun wechselt rein
plötzlich die Richtung und gibt den
Grünen noch einen mit die Menschen
wollen nicht bevormundet werden sie sind
aber bereit zur Veränderung und zur
Einleitung von Veränderungen aber eben
durch Anreize stattverbote sie wollen
nicht bevormundet werden sie wollen
beteiligt werden sie wollen entlastet
werden und nicht belastet werden bei der
Landtagswahl im Oktober hatten sowohl
grüne als auch SPD dramatische Verluste
eingefahren rein konnte sich den Partner
aussuchen die Grünen galten wegen der
jahrelangen zuverlässigen Zusammenarbeit
als großer Favorit bei der Partnerwahl
sie fühlen sich nun getäuscht wer eine
erfolgreiche Zusammenarbeit fortsetzen
will der braucht keine 5 Wochen langen
Sondierungsgespräche sofern hat sich das
angedeutet dass die CDU vorhte den
Koalitionspartner zu wechseln dann wäre
es aus unserer Sicht da angemessen und
fair gewesen das den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern auch vor der Wahl zu sagen das
ist leider ausgeblieben was steckt
hinter dem Richtungswechsel von Boris
rin einige vermuten durch diesen Schritt
wolle er aus dem langen Schatten seines
Vorgängers Volker Buffet treten oder
wachsen da einem neuen starken Mann in
der CDU Flügel zugleich kann sich rein
mit dieser Option innerhalb der Union
eine starke Position erarbeiten weil die
konkurrierenden CDU Ministerpräsident
wenn man so will wüst und Günther sind
im Bündnis mit den Grünen und die
Parteispitze in Berlin ist dabei die
Grünen als Feind zu identifizieren eine
hässische Richtungsentscheidung also mit
möglicherweise bundespolitischer
Bedeutung Boris Rhein scheint es damit
heute richtig gut zu
gehen eine kleine Korrektur es hieß im
Bericht eben das sei die erste große
Koalition in Hessen das stimmt nicht es
gab schon mal eine kurze Zeit die wurde
aber von der SPD geführt also mit
umgekehrten Vorzeichen und jetzt wollen
wir schauen wie das heute alles in
Berlin verarbeitet wird Diana Zimmermann
das ist für die Grünen schon ein
ziemlicher Schlag oder ja die Grünen
auch die bundesgrünen reagieren heute
enttäuscht und angefasst nach diesem für
sie ohnehin schwierigen Jahr jetzt aus
dieser hässischen kalition die
eigentlich als Erfolg GAL zu fliegen ist
der schmerzhaft besonders besorgniserreg
aber ist natürlich das Signal das davon
ausgeht viele auch bei den Grünen haben
sich im Grunde genommen schon darauf
gefreut 2025 in einer schwarzgrünen
Koalition arbeiten zu können aber wir
stellen heute fest schwarzgrün steht
momentan nicht hoch im Kurs die Grünen
haben ein imageprem weiterhin wenn es um
Immigration geht auch wenn sie sich da
von allen Parteien wahrscheinlich am
meisten bewegt haben und spätestens seit
dem heizungsgesetz haben sie eben dieses
Image der verbotspartei wir haben es ja
gerade bei Boris rin gesehen er muss
ihnen noch mal mitteilen dass man eben
über Anreize poliitik machen soll und
nicht über Verbote mhm und hat Boris rin
ja zunächst mal zwar eine
landespolitische hässische Entscheidung
getroffen aber sagt ihr nicht schon auch
etwas aus über die Strategie der CDU
insgesamt rin hat ja die Entscheidung
heute vor allem damit begründet dass man
in der inneren Sicherheit und in der
Migration mit der SPD mehr übereinstimme
und Migration ist eben das Thema was die
Bürger momentan am meisten umtreibt und
das Thema dass der AFD hilft Boris rin
scheint nun heute auf den Kurs des
Parteivorsitzenden eingeschwenkt zu sein
von Friedrich März der schon länger
versucht Vertrauen bei afdwählerern auch
dadurch zu generieren dass er sich
möglichst weit von den Grünen entfernt
hält und Boris rin wechselt damit
sozusagen das Lager verlässt ä seine
Kollegen in NRW und in
Schleswig-Holstein die beide mit den
Grünen kohaliieren und geht zu denen
über die sich eben die grün tatsächlich
auch auf Distanz halten na ja und als
ich jetzt Scholz letztens mehrfach mit
Friedrich Merz drauf haben in Berlin ja
manche auch schon so große
koalitionsglocken Leuten gehört ja
bisschen voreilig würde ich meinen aber
natürlich ist die SPD für die Union in
dieser gesellschaftlichen Situation ein
attraktiver
Partner es ist ja nun so dass die die
Grünen und die SPD zwar ungqu gleich
stark sind aber gerade in der
Migrationsdebatte hat ja Friedrich März
auch tatsächlich dem Kanzler schon
mehrfach vorgeschlagen er sollle die
Grünen rauswerfen und lieber mit der
Union kooperieren bei den momentanen
umfrageerten träumt man in der Union
nicht nur von einer großen Koalition wie
sie sich jetzt in Hessen abzeichnet
sondern eben auch von einer in Berlin
und zwar mit der SPD als Juniorpartner
danke schön für die Analyse an unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
Zimmermann wie eine Bundestagswahl zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt ausgehen würde also
die berühmte
bundestagssonntagsfrage das hat die
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen wieder für ein
ztf Politbarometer erfragt und das gibt
es ausführlich am Ende der Sendung jetzt
oder bereits jetzt schon online auf ztf
heute bzw in der ztf App und die gibt es
übrigens neuerdings auch bei Whatsapp
dafür scannen Sie dann entweder den
angezeigten QR-Code oder sie abonnieren
ZDF heute direkt bei Whatsapp so
bekommen Sie die Nachrichtenlage immer
kompakt zusammengefasst mit Updates am
Morgen und am
Abend der Krieg ist nach Europa
zurückgekehrt das steht so gleich als
erster Satz in den neuen
verteidigungspolitischen Richtlinien die
borus Pistorius jetzt vorgestellt hat
der zweite Satz hat es auch in sich
Deutschland und seine Verbündeten müssen
sich wieder mit einer militärischen
Bedrohung
auseinandersetzen Krieg und Bedrohung
sind sozusagen Trigger Wörter die da
sehr bewusst gesetzt werden sie sollen
etwas auslösen nämlich ein Umdenken in
den Köpfen bei der Bundeswehr und in der
Bevölkerung insgesamt die Botschaft die
gemütlichen Zeiten als man sich
ausschließlich von Freunden umgeben sah
einschließlich der Freunde in Moskau
diese Zeiten sind vorbei und sie kommen
auch so bald nicht wieder auf der
bundeswehrtagung heute hatte
Bundeskanzler Scholz noch eine weitere
Botschaft am Geld werde es nicht mangeln
Thomas Reichard
berichtet auf Kanzler Olaf Scholz wartet
an diesem Morgen eine Herausforderung
die WD er noch die Bundeswehr erwartet
haben im Tagungsraum ist das Licht
vornehm gedämpft so sehr das Scholz ein
Leseproblem hat falls ich noch an die
Regie irgendeinen Wunsch äußern darf ein
bisschen mehr Licht wä auch nicht
schlecht aber dabei geht es hier nicht
um die Tauglichkeit eines tagungsraumes
sondern um die der Bundeswehr
kriegstüchtig müsse sie sein fordert der
Verteidigungsminister
wir brauchen eine Bundeswehr die so
aufgestellt und ausgestattet ist dass
Sie uns in einem Krieg verteidigen kann
und dafür muss die Bundeswehr natürlich
ertüchtigt werden nur eine Bundeswehr
die so stark und abschreckend ist also
kriegstüchtig kann am Ende verhindern
dass es zum Äußersten kommt für das
kwort bekan Pistorius schon zuvor
Gegenwind SPD Fraktionschef Rolf Mütz
nicht fand ist zu matialisch
kriegstüchtig oder kriegsfähig zu werden
wird der Komplexität nicht gerecht der
Kanzler benutzt das kwort heute nicht
aber er verspricht der Bund werde auch
dann 2% der Wirtschaftsleistung für
Verteidigung ausgeben wenn das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr aufgebraucht
ist wie das in spätestens 5 Jahren
klappen soll verrät Scholz indes nicht
die Dimensionen um die es hier geht sind
zwar groß aber es hat schon größere
Dimensionen gegeben wo man gesagt hat
das Problem lösen wir erst demnächst
aber wir werden es definitiv so lösen
dass die Bundeswehr die Mittel bekommt
die sie braucht auch nach Auslaufen des
Sondervermögens das eine große Ansage
allein es fehlt an den Taten der
verteidigungsar muss jetzt steigen er
muss jetzt aufwachsen langsam
kontinuierlich und glaubwürdig die neuen
verteidigungspolitischen Richtlinien
setzen ganz auf Landes und
bündnisverteidigung gegenüber Russland
dafür soll unter anderem eine Brigade
mit rund 5000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
nach litaauen verlegt werden litaauens
oberbefehshaber zu Gast in Berlin sagt
die NATO müsste sich auf das Schlimmste
einstellen damit wir auf einen künftigen
großangelegten Krieg nicht
kalkulierbaren Krieg vorbereitet sind
müssen wir uns anpassen wir müssen uns
ändern dafür wird das
Verteidigungsministerium in Berlin um z
bis 300 Stellen verschlangt keine
Denkverbote verlangt Pistorius auch beim
Umbau der Streitkräfte von seinen
Generalen wir bauen die gesamte
Bundeswehr das heiß wir gucken Bereiche
hinein die zur kriegstüchtigkeit der
Bundeswehr beitragen da ist es wieder
das kwort das zumindest für Pistorius
und seine Militärs die Zukunft der
Truppe beschreiben
soll Krieg Krieg in der Ukraine und
Krieg im Nahen Osten der liegt zwar
nicht mehr auf dem europäischen
Kontinent aber ist gefühlt auch sehr
nahe zumal sich Deutschland Israel
gegenüber verpflichtet fühlt die
israelische Armee kommt derwahl nach
eigenen Angaben be ihrer Bodenoffensive
schneller und erfolgreicher voran als
erwartet schnell wird sie auch sein
müssen angesichts der wachsenden Sorge
der Weltöffentlichkeit über die zivilen
Opfer und die Not der Bevölkerung in
Gaza die israelische Regierung steht
aber auch im eigenen Land unter Druck
für die Angehörigen der Geiseln ist
deren Rückkehr erstmal wichtiger als
militärische Erfolge Henriette deier
berichtet AG Morgen des 7 Oktobers um
6:30 Uhr ging der Alarm los und eine
Masse von Raketen flogen auf unser Haus
im kibutz nos meine Söhne 12 und 16
Jahre waren alleine zu Hause sie
schliefen gingen in den
Schutzraum jeder Mensch der das sieht
kann sich seine eigenen Kinder
vorstellen im eigenen Hause allein in
diesem
Albtraum
Renan GOM eine verzweifelte Mutter die
diesen Zeichentrickfilm machen ließ ein
Hilfeschrei ihre Kinder wieder zu
bekommen gestern ein kurzer
Hoffnungsstrahl der Jüngere Jagel so
hieß es würde vielleicht freigelassen er
ist eine der mindestens 240
Geiseln das letzte was ich hörte war D
mein Jüngster sagte nehmt mich nicht ich
bin zu
jung nirgends auf der Welt sollten Teil
von so etwas sein Kinder ihre Familien
leiden auch im Gasastreifen auch heute
sind Menschen auf der Flucht von Norden
nach Süden deutlich mehr als in den
vergangenen Wochen es solle weiter
stundenweise sichere Korridore für
Zivilisten und Hilfslieferung geben
bestätigte gestern israels
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu der
israelische Militärsprecher sagte auf
Nachfrage zu Verhandlung zur
geiselfrage werden keine echte Chance
verpassen um die Geiseln zurückzubringen
weder operative Chancen noch
geheimdienstliche und auch nicht solche
wie die angesprochenen Verhandlungen
Außenministerin berbock betont bei ihrer
Nahostreise heute noch einmal Israels
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung setzt sich
auch für die Geiseln ein würden sie sich
nicht selbstverteidigen um ihre Menschen
zu
schützen Israel verteidigt sich gegen
einen Gegner der es von der Landkarte
ausradieren möchte eine Waffenruhe so
die diplomatischen Hoffnungen könnte
auch helfen die israelischen Geiseln zu
befreien sie wurden nicht einfach so
mitgenommen sie sollen einen Zweck
erfüllen und nur solange sie leben
können Sie diesem Zweck dienen und ich
hoffe so sehr dass das wahr ist und dass
sie sicher
sind Kinder als Spielball für
Verhandlung die angekündigte Freilassung
ihres Sohnes wurde heute abgesagt Renan
GOM sagt sie hoffe dass Ihre jungst
wenigstens zusammen
sein und jetzt geht's erstmal bei dir
weiter Heinz mit anderen Nachrichten des
Tages der Bundestag hat die staatliche
Finanzierung parteinahe Stiftungen jetzt
zum ersten Mal auf eine gesetzliche
Grundlage gestellt zu den
Voraussetzungen gehört demnach dass sich
die Stiftung für die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und den
Gedanken der Völkerverständigung
einsetzt und die Partei der sie nahe
steht mindestens dreimal hinterinander
in Fraktionsstärke im Bundestag ist die
AFD die erst in der zweiten Wahlperiode
im Bundestag sitzt bewertete das Gesetz
in der Debatte als
verfassungswidrig ebenfalls heute im
Bundestag eine globale Mindeststeuer von
15% für internationaltätige
Großunternehmen der Bundestag stimmte
für die Umsetzung einer entsprechenden
EURichtlinie in nationales Recht der
Reform soll verhindern dass Großkonzerne
ihre Gewinne in Länder Verschieben in
denen sie weniger Steuern zahlen müssen
das Finanzministerium rechnet dadurch
2026 mit mehr Einnahmen von mehr als 900
Millionen
Euro in Spanien hat Ministerpräsident
Sanches vier Wochen nach den Wahlen eine
Mehrheit im Parlament hinter sich auch
die baskischen Nationalist sagten ihm
ihre Unterstützung zu wie zuvor bereits
die Katalanen gegen die Absprache mit
den Katalanen gab es gestern Abend in
Madrid wieder Proteste die Kritiker
werfen Sanches vor für die Unterstützung
bei der Regierungsbildung ein
Amnestiegesetz für katalanische
unabhängigkeitsbefürworter zugesagt zu
haben auch in Polen läuft die
Regierungsbildung bislang hat diesen
Auftrag der bisherige Ministerpräsident
morwietzki dessen Partei hatte bei der
par w aber die absolute Mehrheit
verfehlt nun hat das Bündnis um den
ehemaligen EU Ratspräsidenten Donald
Tusk eine Vereinbarung für eine
mehrheitsfähige Koalition unterzeichnet
Tusk sagte das Bündnis sei bereit sofort
die Regierung zu übernehmen sobald er
einen offiziellen Auftrag dazu
habe es ist ein bislang einzigartiges
Abkommen Australien sonst in
flüchtlingsfragen sehr restriktiv wird
Menschen aus dem südseeinselstadt tuwalu
asylgewehren weil deren Lebensraum durch
die Klimakrise über kurz oder lang
unbewohnbar wird zunächst geht es um 280
Menschen jährlich tuwalu hat 11200
Einwohner auf neun Inseln zwei davon
sind bereits im mer versunken im
Gegenzug erhält Australien ein Vetorecht
bei tuvalus außen und Sicherheitspolitik
dabei geht es laut Beobachtern vor allem
um den wachsenden Einfluss Chinas im
Südpazifik
das gehört zu den Grausamkeiten des
Klimawandels dass solche kleinen
Inselstaaten die ersten Opfer sind
obwohl sie selbst praktisch nichts zu
ihrem eigenen Untergang beigetragen
haben in Unschuld versunken sozusagen
während sich die großen Industrieländer
nach wie vor schwer tun mit Klimaschutz
und auch mit Umweltschutz
Renaturierung ist so ein Thema an dem
sich die Geister scheiden in der
Europäischen Union wird darüber heftig
gestritten renaturieren das heißt also
unter anderem flächentill zuulegen gilt
Umweltschützern als unabdingbar um
Lebensräume für Tiere und Pflanzen zu
erhalten aber auch um Hochwassergefahren
zu reduzieren das geht allerdings auf
Kosten landwirtschaftlicher Nutzflächen
in Brüssel gibt es dazu jetzt einen
mühsam errungenen Kompromiss Florian
Neuhann
berichtet Brüsseler verhandlungsnächte
enden oft wie diese mit einem Tweet mit
Fotos von en Verhandlern und mit stolzen
Stimmen es ist das erste Gesetz
überhaupt in Europa dass die Natur nicht
nur schützen sondern sie auch
wiederherstellen
wird dabei war kaum ein europäisches
Gesetz so umstritten wie das zur
Wiederherstellung der Natur bekämpft von
Landwirten vor und konservativen um
Manfred Weber im Parlament aus Sorge vor
zu hohen Auflagen doch der Aufstand
scheiterte knapp das Gesetz wurde weiter
verhandelt bis zur vorläufigen Einigung
gestern Nacht demnach soll bis 2030 auf
20% der Fläche von wän über Gewässer bis
zu mohen die Natur wiederhergestellt
werden welche Maßnahmen die Staaten
ergreifen lässt man offen für Landwirte
aber gibt es keine Verpflichtung mehr
Flächen stillzulegen diese Ausnahme
hatten die Konservativen
durchgesetzt wir diskutieren ganz viel
über das Thema Ernährungssicherheit dann
kann ich nicht immer mehr
landwirtschaftliche Produkt
landwirtschaftliche Nutzfläche
zurückfahren eine bittere Pille für die
Grünen doch nehmen Sie lieber den
Kompromiss als gar kein Gesetz wenn wir
die Natur immer weiter zurückdrengen
gefährden wir unsere eigenen
überlebensgrundlagen und deshalb ist
dieses Gesetz so elementar und die
Bauern sind auch mit den Ausnahmen von
heute nicht zufrieden es fehlt ihnen an
Geld trotz einiger Verbesserungen ist
dieser Vorschlag rückwärts gerichtet und
setzt auf Ordnungsrecht Landwirte müssen
natürlich auch mit Naturschutzmaßnahmen
Umweltschutzmaßnahmen Geld verdienen
können wäre das ein gewöhnliches Gesetz
wäre die Geschichte hier zu Ende die
Einigung würde vom EU-Parlament
durchgewunken sonst reine Formsache
diesmal nicht noch hoffen manche
konservative das Gesetz stoppen zu
können der Kampf ums europäische
Naturschutzgesetz ist noch nicht
entschieden wer Immobilien kaufen oder
kaufen möchte wird jetzt bei dir
aufmerksam zuhören Halz ja es gibt neue
Zahlen zur Preisentwicklung auf dem
Immobilienmarkt vom Verband Deutscher
Pfandbriefbanken demnach ging es im
dritten Quartal weiter nach unten mit
den Preisen Frank betmann wieso hält
dieser Abwärtstrend so an weil sich
eines kaum geändert hat die Zinsen sind
weiterhin hoch das finanzieren von
Immobilien bleibt teuer ergo geht die
Preiskorrektur weiter von Quartal zu
Quartal vergessen darf man dabei
allerdings nicht dass die Preise
jahrelang nur die andere Richtung kanen
nach oben nun aber fallen sie und zwar
in allen immobilienklassen
Wohnimmobilien verbelichten sich auf
Jahressicht um über 6 %.
Einzelhandelsimmobilien um über neun und
Büroimmobilien Garum über 10 %.
verstärkt wird der Preisverfall bei den
Gewerbeimmobilien durch Trends wie
Online Shopping und Homeoffice fachleute
schätzen daher auch dass sich der
preisabschwung bei Wohnimmobilien eher
beruh könnte als bei den gewerblich
genutzten Objekten vom kaufen bzw
verkaufen zum Mieten wie sieht es da aus
ja auch da verstätigt sich ein Trend die
Mietpreise steigen weiter wer nicht mehr
kaufen kann der Sucht was zu mieten das
Angebot an Mietwohnungen wächst aber in
diesem Tempo nicht mit darum steigen die
Preise im dritten Quartal jetzt noch mal
kräftig besonders deutlich in Metropolen
wie Berlin wo die Neuvertragsmieten um
fast 9% gestiegen sind in in München um
über 5%. es fehlt Wohnraum die
Bautätigkeit lahmt klare Hinweise dass
ich daran in Kürze etwas ändert sucht
man derzeit vergebens Frank betmann
vielen
Dank seit Monaten laufen die
Tarifverhandlungen im groß und
Einzelhandel bisher ohne Ergebnis die
Gewerkschaft werdi hat erneut bundesweit
zu Warnstreiks aufgerufen heute in
Berlin die Hauptforderung der
Beschäftigten 2,50 € mehr pro Stunde die
Arbeitgeber verlangen jetzt ein
Spitzengespräch auf Bundesebene die
Verhandlungen auf Länderebene sei
gescheitert deshalb droht werdi auch das
Weihnachtsgeschäft zu
bestreiten in gut einer Woche steht für
die Fußballnationalmannschaft das
nächste Testspiel an und Bundestrainer
nagelsmann hat Neulinge ins Team Berufen
darunter Bremens Stürmer Marvin
duchch für Marvin duxch geht ein Traum
in Erfüllung aber mit 32 Toren aus 63
Bundes spielen hat er sich durchaus
empfohlen er ist einer der frech nach
vorne spielt der 29-Jährige der seit
2021 für Werder Bremen kickt ist dort
bekannt als der Mann mit dem gewissen
Instinkt duch ist nach der mialer
Verletzung im Champions League Spiel
gegen galatasarai eine Option um Angriff
für Bundestrainer Julian nagelsmann und
vielleicht gibt es ja eine
Wiedervereinigung mit seinem ehemaligen
Werder Sturmpartner Niklas
fku so viel von uns und jetzt gibt es
wie schon angekündigt das neue Barometer
und das präsentiert Ihnen anche
pieer herzlich willkommen zum
Politbarometer einen historischen Moment
so hat Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz die
Einigung von Bund und Ländern in der
Asylpolitik Anfang der Woche genannt zu
den Beschlüssen gehören weniger
Leistungen für Asylbewerber schnellere
Asylverfahren und schnellere
Abschiebungen auch den Befragten im
Politbarometer brennt das Thema unter
den Nägeln für mehr als die Hälfte ist
der Themenkomplex flüchtlingeasyl und
Integration das wichtigste politische
Problem im Moment Energie und Klima
folgt abgeschlagen auf Platz 2 dass
Deutschland die vielen Flüchtlinge aus
Krisengebieten verkraften kann die
aktuell zu uns kommen Glauben
35%. 63% meinen das nicht dass ich durch
die jetzt beschlossene Verschärfung der
Regelungen Menschen davon abschrecken
lassen nach Deutschland zu kommen sagt
nicht mal jeder fünf
mehr als Dreiviertel glauben das nicht
außerdem beschlossen 7500 € pro
Flüchtling und ja sollen die Kommunen
vom Bund bekommen dass der Bund die
Kommunen damit jetzt ausreichend
unterstützt meint trotzdem nicht einmal
jeder Fünfte mehr als zwei Drittel sehen
immer noch nicht genug Unterstützung
durch den Bund am kompetentesten
bewerten die Befragten beim Thema Flucht
und Asyl die Union mit deutlichem
Abstand vor allen anderen Parteien ein
den klaren Vorsprung haben CDU und CSU
auch bei der Sonntagsfrage wenn schon am
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD
auf 16 % + 1 CDU CSU 30% unverändert die
Grünen auf 15 % + 1 die FDP müsste mit
5% um den Wiedereinzug in den Bundestag
bangen die AFD käme wieder auf 21% die
Linke nur noch auf 4% -1 und die Freien
Wähler auf
3%. die Union als stärkste Kraft könnte
sich bei diesen Ergebnissen entweder die
SPD oder die Grünen als
Koalitionspartner aussuchen für beide
zweier Optionen würde es reichen ein
Bündnis mit der AFD haben CDU und CSU ja
ausgeschlossen weit von jeder
Regierungsbeteiligung entfernt ist die
Linke am Dienstag will die
Bundestagsfraktion der Linken ihre
Auflösung
einleiten nach dem Austritt von Sarah
Wagenknecht und ihren Gefolgsleuten aus
der Partei gilt die Fraktion als
politisch tot das angekündigte Bündnis
Sara Wagenknecht hat dagegen gute
Startchancen 13% wollen die angekündigte
wagenknechtpartei bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl wahrscheinlich oder sogar
sicher wählen vor allem auf bisherige
Anhänger der Linkspartei und der AFD
könnte sie sich
stützen gerade im Osten könnte das
Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht der AFD große
Konkurrenz machen im Osten kann sich
jeder vierte gut vorstellen die
angekündigt Partei zu wählen und das vor
den drei Landtagswahlen in Sachsen
Thüringen und Brandenburg im kommenden
Jahr in unserer Liste der zehn
wichtigsten Politikerinnen und Politiker
wird Sarah Wagenknecht für ihren
Parteiaustritt aus der linken allerdings
abgestraft auf der Skala von + 5 bis -5
nach Sympathie und Leistung landet Alice
Weidel auf dem letzten Platz -2,6
verschlechtert Sarah Wagenknecht kommt
nur noch auf -1,4 deutlich schlechter
Annalena berbur auf Platz 8 -0,3
verbessert Karl Lauterbach ebenfalls
-0,3 leicht verbessert Friedrich märz -
0,2 leicht verbessert aber er kommt auch
bei den eigenen Parteianhänger nur auf
schwache Zustimmungswerte Platz 5
Christian Lindner - 0,2 deutlich
verbessert der Bundeskanzler auf Platz 4
-0,1 leicht zugelegt aufallen stark
verbessert hat sich Robert habbeck jetzt
bei 0,0 auf Platz 2 Markus Söder mit
0,1 Boris Pistorius an der Spitze mit
1,6 weiterhin als einziger Politiker mit
einem deutlich positiven
Wert nach den Terrorattacken der Hamas
in Israel ist das israelische Militär in
den Gazastreifen vorgedrungen mit dem
Ziel die Terrorgruppe
auszuschalten dass das militärische
Vorgehen Israels im Gazastreifen
gerechtfertigt ist sagt genau die Hälfte
der Befragten etwas mehr als ein Drittel
findet es nicht
gerechtfertigt dass Israel die Hamas so
schwächen kann dass sie keine Gefahr
mehr darstellt glaubt nur etwa jeder
vierte zwei Drittel meinen dass das
nicht gelingen wird wie die
Bundesregierung Israel aktuell
unterstützt halten 54% für gerade
richtig 10 % sagen die Bundesregierung
tut zu wenig für Israel mehr als jeder
fünfte findet aber dass zu viel
Unterstützung aus Deutschland kommt vor
allem Anhänger der AFD der Linken der
FDP und der Freien Wähler sind dieser
Meinung
85 Jahre nach der Reichsprogromnacht ist
das Thema Antisemitismus auch bei uns
leider immer noch nicht Geschichte mehr
als die Hälfte sagen dass die
Judenfeindlichkeit hier zuulande groß
oder sehr groß ist nicht so groß sagt
rund ein
Drittel das war unser Bericht über die
Stimmung im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZF Text auf Seite
165 in der zfheute App und auf
zfheute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe wen
zustande kommen Information zur Methodik
und zu den Qualitätsstandard finden Sie
unter Politbarometer
ZDF vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt's dann am 24
November nach dem Wetter folgt hier
gleich die heuthow Ihnen noch ein
schönes Wochenende auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht schneiz im
Schwarzwald und auch am Alpenrand
oberhalb von etwa 700 bis 1000 m und
auch morgen Vormittag fällt noch
weiterer Schnee im Thüringerwald im
Erzgebirge im oberpfels im Bayerischen
Wald und am Alpenrand im Laufe des Tages
lassen die Regen und schneefeller aber
mehr und mehr nach heute Nacht kann es
vielleicht sogar mal für ein kleines
Gewitter reichen am ehsten trocken
bleibt ist ganz im Norden und ganz im
Osten am Alpenrand sinken die
Temperaturen bis -1° milder bleibt die
Nacht am niederrehein im Münsterland
oder auch auf den Ostfriesischen Inseln
mit 6°. tagsüber warten uns dann
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 4° an den
Alpen und 10° am Rhein oder an der
Nordsee der Vormittag wird meist noch
trüb da fällt Regen zum Teil eben auch
Schnee hier im Nordosten haben sie noch
eine Chance auf Sonne hinter dem Regen
lockern die Wolken im Südwesten
allerdings schon wieder auf ein kleines
Zwischenhoch wird sich dann am
Nachmittag noch weiter nach Osten
schieben dafür regnet es hier weiter und
die Sonne im Nordosten verschwindet mehr
und mehr der Sonntag wird insgesamt
etwas ruhiger es kann auch einige
Regenschauer im Osten geben und
schneeregenfälle ganz im Süden an den
Temperaturen ändert sich vorerst wenig
die liegen auch am Sonntag bei 4 bis 10°
aber dann wird es von Tag zu Tag milder
am Mittwoch erwarten wir im Südwesten
dann schon wieder 16° dazu wird es sehr
regnerisch und sehr stürmisch es droht
in Süddeutschland vielleicht sogar hoch
guten Abend